we're back and now we know what the hell
that footprint was or at least I know
what that was
oh I told you all would be explained
it's our trap yes so it's exactly what I
shouted so this is um uh what was it
oppas lost days I think is what it was
the last days of op op is no halo around
her The Last Temptation about what do
you want betray me uh uh Wow
dark cave you think eros story and the
previous one was dark holy crap you know
I had a feeling going into this I was
like okay I think I know what this is
gonna be this is gonna be a back track
of all the stuff that happened while
they were off having their adventures
and I was also saying I bet this is
gonna be like ah was it Land Before Time
or americantale where it's just like the
more we can beat the out of this
thing the more you're gonna feel happy
when he gets home make sure you don't go
jump through the flaming hoop except you
don't even get to the point where he
gets home they draw it out even longer
so that's you know delightfully cruel
um but great commentary and animal
cruelty I was like I'm like good I'm
just like I'm never going to a circus
ever this is like holy but for me
so going in that's always the thing
where it's like that avatar always or
throws me for a little bit of a loop is
that you think from the beginning of the
episode okay I got this one figured out
and for the most part I kinda did until
he got to that guru um the person that's
just sort of laying there I guess had a
vision or a dream that he's supposed to
help the avatar we know nothing else
about him I'd actually be fine if we
never do find anything else about like
you know this is his only appearance
like I'd be cool like because it was
actually very uh you know aim for it
that happens once a toy by other
characters for the little for the little
that they had him there I thought was
actually very effective but uh it felt
like here's a creature has gone through
so much I love the line when the guru
says you're so much of your trust is now
been replaced with fear and we have to
work on that I like that I thought that
was a very poignant line and I liked how
humans work the same way
oh yeah well exactly the the visual of
and they realizes the visual of Appa
when he is I think when he meets up with
what was a Sookie is their name ah the
the warrior girl uh when he meets up
with her and he is just so I mean he's
dirty he's got spikes all over him and
he's got bruising he's got chains on and
stuff like that
and those images I always think are so
good because you know that again when
you get to the point where he's gonna
return home or he's gonna be clean
against it it's gonna feel so good and I
think this is saying any I mean time
though yes well our well and I think it
is it was like rushing this Christ show
you have to have that harshness for a
way does get to the groove I agree
the girl really has to see yeah what
he's been through and can show just how
difficult the healing process is to get
the show didn't pull any punches like
and I respect that because it's like no
we're really gonna torture the hell out
of this animal so that you know that's
why I think it works I think you know
adults can be just douchebags and you
know what can you do about that but I
think sometimes kids don't realize when
they're just picking on an animal or
just what they think is having fun you
mess an animal up pretty easily yeah oh
yeah right I I need it when people's get
pets for their toddlers or something and
I'm just like oh my god like no don't
don't get a kitten for your
three-year-old doesn't work that way
well then people are always so shy when
they go to a shelter like why is this
dog so angry it's like you know exactly
like they've come from a family there
are people have just abused have not
cared about it and nobody expect a job I
should know doing when you get an animal
that includes adopting an animal who may
have been previously abused and that
includes bringing an animal into your
home with children who may not know
better
mm-hm I'm
the more you know Isaiah there's a
little lesson for today
um and I try to eat some good fighting
with the three uh we should color the
name for a moment art the evil Daria
change the Daria tree oh yeah the the
Azula and the gymnast at the board girl
that's a trio of Awesomeness um and you
know you have a nice fight there but
what I like what I got out of this even
more than like the animal cruelty
comment here
I got Frankenstein cuz I got everything
he comes across every person he comes
across just somehow even the ones who
want to help him like even zuki has to
like get the fires again no go away go
yeah if I you're my friend I try to burn
like what the hell oh they all scene was
so cruel yeah I'm like no I know what
you're doing at Sookie but can't this
damn lice and catch a break what weren't
like them to get on the bikes at him fly
off I saw a question out of it but um oh
but but I think that makes the scene all
the more effective when they get to the
pillow was he they're trusting at that
point maybe she no he was no no she
helped him I mean you know she helped
well you could argue they couldn't get
on top of him in time cuz Azula the are
two were right there and could've been
week two we don't know how much it could
have carried um I guess but well
regardless I think what maybe Sookie's
in a decision when he gets tired of the
Guru and he's laying down and I like
that he came to get up without him
growling and he has to wait it out I
thought that you know like literally the
whole day until he's asleep and I really
like he has to do that a couple times he
can't actually go up and touch him until
he's asleep so he has to wait two days
in a row to do that so I thought again
it just shows the distrust has been
built in him as I think I was telling
you ahead of time cuz you hated the
episode where Aang hides the the message
yeah from the father um it was not one
of my favorite episodes either I think I
was a little more accepting of it than
you were but I'm like yes kind of
handled sloppily but I know what they
were going for Aang's afraid he's the
hundred years of being alone now he's
gonna lose his only friends but you're
right it was kind of they kind of really
just
oh but we need to stick with our friend
Oh he happened to be out there it's it's
it should have been like maybe two
episodes we could've dragged it a little
bit enough and it's so hokey but so I
was giving you the warning because I was
like yeah Aang's gonna go a little
douchey again you know his frame is
justified here if they know yeah it's
justified but the first time I saw it I
actually the funny thing is I had less
trouble with the episode you were
talking about in the first season than I
did with this one and I I thought
overall it was justified but I still was
like man like Toph pretty much blew out
her muscles you know trying to hold the
tower up and they're all trying to help
and he's just you know anxious pretty
much I shut up I'm gonna leave you to
starve in the desert so I can you know
hop on my glider and find you know Appa
um that's the point where I said loses
like I know you really care about Appa
but they can die but so and the one
thing is so I said you know warning
Aang's gonna get moved do she again as
he works through this but and yes to
some degree it is justified I got
through it I was patient with it because
this was a part of the series I had not
seen yet and this episode is the payoff
this is such a payoff to putting up with
Ang's sort of you know being so kind of
jerky to his friends because he's upset
about Appa because now you see what Appa
went through and why Aang is so
terrified and pissed off and being a
jerk and he's like you guys don't get it
I know I I thought the payoff for that
was really really great in a way that I
think in others I think a cheap
animation would have just had Oh Appa
gets into a little trouble and he's
found and this bad but I think to see
that torture I'm getting so ups for
seeing this episode though because that
everything is doing still feels like
emotionally it was building on top of
each other because you have a kid who
feels this great guilt from you know for
going and leaving for a hundred years
and they comes back all this misery so
he already feels like that's his fault
but now you have pretty much his oldest
friend even if it is a pet
is taken away and not only is he taken
away but he was responsible for him and
he said directly responsible for him and
now he is gone and he could not take
care of him and I think that even
something worse than when he goes inside
the drive he puts the ice cube around
him because like I said it stuff happens
when he disappears this is someone he
was directly responsible for and well
you do find out later that the
airbenders have a real connection with
their bison there basically yeah like
childhood friends and stuff and so I I
get it and I guess the only thing we're
lost you swear he's just like well have
fun fending in the desert for yourself
I'm like you know needs of the many
needs of the world but I like but I can
see him and I know I don't I can't lose
him too I don't like I know what you're
gonna say and you're gonna pull D he's a
kid card no not nothing he's a cute kid
card that he has for the responsibility
of him has lost so many people and it's
had a war happen and he wasn't there for
it and granted he has new friends now
but now it's like the only creature that
he made a connection to long ago the
only connection to that past and he was
responsible for is gone and he wants to
say to himself
no I ok we'll fix this I will not know
how this happened so fair enough a bunch
of people died because I went into the
ice so my newfound friends that I'm so
desperate to hold on to that I lie about
their father now I'm going to say they
can starve in the desert because no
but I know but over Saul you
know he can come back and he does come
back but sick does come back but I'll
tell ya watching it I was like hope he
can find them cuz it was like holy
no but I mean the emotions take him over
so much that he has to go and search
because you can see him just saying no I
can't lose him too like that was an
actual creature I was responsible for it
it's one of the few times where for a
show I think that normally sets a really
good example for kids it's one of the
borderline moments I'm like I'm not sure
that's the message I want to send to a
bunch of kids like well ok if you're
gonna go your
you know fair enough but when it is two
episodes to analyze it yo and say me now
I will say this one it's also then done
that's why I think the payoff is worth
it cuz when you see what Apple went
through you you get like there is a
payoff which is you see that opera is in
real danger it's not just that Oh operas
gonna be sold to you know some other
owner and maybe he's gonna have a nice
life it's like no but here's the last of
these creatures - I mean see yeah I
guess he is
so many jobless nearly going to die
because of this and I think that's an
immense payoff for something that at
least for me I was kind of like I'm
tolerating this and I still think it's
okay but it's definitely some of the
harder episodes to get there because I'm
like Manning they're just trying to help
quick well I mean yet I I saw their
national yeah Homer chosen and just like
you know maybe we can get you a new
bison No thank you no I think for him if
he really lost up and found out that
Appa was like dead or gone I mean for
him to be like okay I I have failed
everything like I have stood for I there
is nothing I can do
and as I said I think overall it works
and I'm saying it works because of this
episode if Appa did not go through
anything harsh as a result of this I
would look back on those episodes of Eng
just leaving his friends in the desert
have been going yeah kind of a dick move
like I know you're upset but I see it a
little more but at the same time yeah
it's a good episode to have I like again
that they add a little bit more instead
of just him suffering and getting back I
like him coming across the Guru I just
feel something about that part to be
elevated it a little beyond because they
have this on rant that message I I think
that's one of the best line that's one
of the best lines in the entire show
like in your top 20 lines or whatever
that what about like you've replaced
trust with fear mm-hmm so the one of the
best written lines in any show I'm not
not just for animals I'm Eli like you
said you're just for people that so many
people come out well thanks for watching
I mean it well again just like the uncle
hero episode I was saying that is the
center of it this is another example or
that one line could you could argue is
one of the Centers of the entire show
because how many characters in this
operating on that level hmm you know
that is Zuko's entire story you've
replaced trust with fear
you know so many of the characters all
the struggles they go through you've
replaced trust with fear and does the
same thing you know in many cases I you
know I would argue even that and getting
up and leaving his friends behind them
the desert was replacing trust with fear
you know maybe he should have trusted
that maybe he'll be able to find him
later but instead his feared ran away
from his friends so yeah as I said I
think it works it's just you have to
kind of put up with it because I was
like wow like wow banning damn but you
know it works because of that payoff and
that central theme in this episode I
think connects it together so I am
saying it works okay I mean yeah so
there you go uh yeah just another good
episode I curious what horrible you're
tsuki curious would uh we're demented
bossing say is up to now cuz that place
creeps me out when I would tell all the
truth say we're good yeah I thought a
lab on Sing se was gonna be like a Gary
episode like a Tales from the Crypt or
something cuz I was like this place is
scary know the whole I love the tour
guides I just did those plastic smiles
just welcome to Ba Sing se
oh you see your job it's like where's
Judy no this is Judy now that's not Judy
yeah it is I knew Judy yeah that whole
Manchurian Candidate thing they've got
is freaky I I thought it was great so so
very cool well that's this episode and
I'm sure you'll see him in the future
you'll definitely see me in the future
um until the future